parti de sarrebruck en allemagne ce
train de rejoindre cerbère à destination
de l'espagne l'un des wagons-citernes
situé au centre du convoi laisser fuir
son chargement d'acide chlorhydrique une
procédure d'urgence a été déclenché vers
10 heures la sncf a alerté les pompiers
de côte-d'or
le train était d'arrêter au pk 344 à
saint-usage tout près de la gare de
saint jean de losne
on a engagé
27 sapeurs pompiers six engins dont deux
unités spécialisées en risque chimique
pour pouvoir contenir la fuite et
trouver une solution de transvasement de
du produit qui reste un large périmètre
de sécurité a été mis en place avec le
concours des gendarmes pendant toute la
durée des opérations
le wagon citerne qui fuyait se trouvait
au milieu du tram il a été isolé sur une
autre voie pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de risque de pollution de nappes
phréatiques puisque la suite et contenus
en sur le ballast sncf
en tout cas jusqu'à temps qu'on
intervienne et puis depuis quelque temps
nous avons mis des moyens de
récupération sous le wagon qui étaient
isolés pour pouvoir contenir le produits
récupérés dans des bacs tampons en
attendant un autre wagon qui viendra et
on fera le transvasement entre les deux
wagons pour pour que le wagon fuyards
swami sont mis à vide
la circulation des ter entre dijon et
bourg en bresse devrait normalement
reprendre demain matin